il
au sommaire ce soir le suspense se
présidentielle en pologne lech walesa
mènerait d'une très courte tête devant
son concurrent néo-communistes les
suites de la grogne dans les universités
françaises la semaine qui s'ouvre sera
décisive
'l'annonce par jean arthuis d'une
possible suppression de l'abattement
fiscal de 20 % au profit des salariés
une petite visite au salon de la future
maman et du bébé est enfin le sourire de
la nouvelle miss monde
madame monsieur bonsoir comment dit-on
suspense en anglais réponse suspense
l'excitation est à son comble
outre-manche avant l'interview
programmée demain soir par la bbc de la
princesse diana qui devrait entre autres
évoqué les soubresauts de sa vie privée
peut-être une petite vengeance après des
confessions de son époux charles qui
toujours à la télévision avait avoué
l'avoir trompée reportage de notre
correspondant à londres bernard lebrun
un modèle de fidélité conjugale
suspense infernal cinq jours que cette
bande annonce de panorama le plus ancien
est sérieux magazine de la bbc pas assez
repas sur les écrans sans que personne
ne connaisse le contenu de cette fameuse
interview exclusive réponse demain à
21h40
en attendant la presse britannique du
dimanche ronge son frein en pratiquant
son sport favori la spéculation et de
poser des milliers de questions pas
toujours avec respect comme celle ci est
elle devenue cinglé interroge le daily
mirror le sunday telegraph et celui qui
s'avance le plus loin sur le contenu de
l'interview
pourquoi détruire est l'avenir de mes
enfants dit ou plutôt dire et diana et
de placer dans sa voix c'est quatre
points
je n'abandonnerai pas le pays c'est
triste un couple qui se sépare
je n'attends pas de pitié je suis forte
je suis là pour servir et heureuse de le
faire et enfin à la question centrale
divorce ou non non il y a deux enfants
impliqués répondrait la princesse mais
en grande bretagne aujourd'hui le
contenu importe peu par rapport à la
manière
la princesse a parlé et c'est déjà
énorme tout a commencé mardi précisément
le jour du 47e anniversaire de charles
alors en visite en allemagne la bbc
lâche sa bombe
1h10 l'interview le secret avait été
bien gardé c'est un jeune journaliste de
32 ans martin bashir qui a décroché le
scoop ici à kensington palace résidence
de la princesse
seules huit personnes étaient au courant
le gouverneur de la bbc lui même ne le
savais pas et devinez pourquoi parce que
sa femme et dames de compagnie de la
reine et helle risque est de prévenir sa
majesté même effet de surprise chez les
plus fins limiers de la famille royale
comme ici au daily telegraph où l'on ne
savait rien
j'ai détresse après c'était
extraordinaire extraits j'ai parlé
médiatement avec le packing thales et là
il m'a aidé nous ne savons pas c'est
incroyable aujourd'hui devant kensington
palace une brigade de photographes à
monter la garde
à la sortie du palais mais diana n'a pas
bougé sa majesté n'a rien changé à son
programme demain soir elle préside un
gala de charité en ville avec le prince
philip
mais soyons sûrs que tous les
magnétoscopes du palais tourneront à
21h40
et puisque nous en sommes au chapitre
des amours près
sierre ce petit clin d'oeil et que la
présence incognito mariage hier à
copenhague du prince eu hakim du
danemark de monsieur x
claude occasion ce retraité français qui
a déjà réussi à s'infiltrer dans de très
nombreuses cérémonies officielles en
compagnie de pascal douce et bon
cherchez l'intrus
certes les mariés font partie des grands
de ce monde mais sauf le respect les
altesses n'étaient pas les plus célèbres
à leurs propres noces non en toute
subjectivité la vedette était bien le
plus connu des inconnus
claude cazes ision français 64 ans
retraité du pays sa spécialité s'inviter
dans toutes les grandes cérémonies
claude était donc tout naturellement au
mariage du prince joseph needham nac la
blague était organisée par un journal de
copenhague
elle fait rire ses auteurs les lecteurs
votre serviteur n'est pas les services
de sécurité demeurent
nous ne poursuivrons pas ceux qui ont
fait ça s'il y a quelqu'un à blâmer
c'est nous et nous seuls mais il
n'aurait pas dû faire
c'est imprudent les services de sécurité
français non plus n'avait pas aimé la
blague 8 mai 95 claude quasi zients
pause au milieu de 53 chefs d'état
reçues par jacques chirac
deux mois plus tard le voici aux côtés
de megan indurain et de l'infante
d'espagne
cette fois ci il s'est quand même fait
prendre il en a été quitte pour une nuit
au poste
mais parions que si un jour il paraît
avec le pape
on se demandera certainement mais qui
est donc le mont blanc à côté de case is
you
revenons aux choses sérieuses en france
le gouvernement prépare une importante
réforme fiscale qui devrait être
présenté au début de l'année prochaine
invité du club de la presse d'europe
numéro 1 tout à l'heure jean arthuis a
fait sensation en indiquant que le
ministère des finances
réfléchissez à une éventuelle
suppression de l'abattement de 20% au
profit des salariés la suppression pure
et simple de cet abattement de 20 % pose
un problème à partir d'un salaire de 250
ou 260 mille francs et c'est assez
compliqué parce que s'ajoutent à cela
des considérations de barèmes familiale
de nombre de parts mais je confirme il
est dans l'intention du gouvernement de
remettre en cause tous ces abattements
notamment l'abattement de 20%
interrogé à ce sujet lors de l'émission
7 sur 7 tout à l'heure alain juppé s'est
contenté de déclarer ce n'est pas un
projet c'est une idée rien n'est décidé
le premier sera également confirmé que
les familles nombreuses et les familles
modestes ne seront pas touchés par la
fiscalisation des allocations familiales
la semaine qui s'ouvre s'annonce
décisive dans la crise ouverte dans les
universités apaisement ou au contraire
extension voir durcissement du mouvement
étudiant
tout dépendra du bilan tirer de la
concertation ouverte au ministère de
l'éducation et surtout de l'ampleur de
la journée nationale d'action et de
manifestations prévue mardi marie-pierre
farkas
au rang de grève à paris viii le
mouvement étudiant a marqué une pause
dominicale simple occupation symbolique
des facs pendant le week end va sur 90
ont débrayé depuis le début de la
semaine on peut pour l'instant parler
que de malaise diffus et de colère
sporadiques les étudiants et tous dans
leur université les professeurs les
soutiennent officiellement depuis
vendredi le ministre de l'éducation lui
même reconnaît qu'il faut s'attaquer
très vite qu'à une réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur que cette année
même
que nous avons l'intention d'apporter
toutes les réponses aux problèmes de
fond qui se posent
sentais bien que le malaise qui
s'exprime sous la forme de demandes de
postes ou de demandes de crédits pour
l'université d'un malaise beaucoup plus
général et cela ne pourra se faire
qu'avec l'invitation au dialogue n'a pas
été totalement entendu puisque
aujourd'hui plusieurs délégations de
metz perpignan montpellier paris était à
toulouse pour mettre en place une
stratégie nationale
vous voulez faire un appel pour demander
un traitement global de la situation
d'enseignement supérieur en france et
nous sommes mais pour ça il fallait un
mouvement national et donc il fallait un
petit peu c'est préparer les premières
structures de ce mouvement national le
texte adopté en commun réclame deux
milliards de francs 6000 postes
d'enseignants en refusant les solutions
au cas par cas il pourrait préfigurer le
durcissement du mouvement
ce dimanche était la journée nationale
du secours catholique une association
qui s'apprête à fêter ses 50 ans
d'existence et qui compte quelque 72
mille bénévoles répartis dans son si
délégation départementale
malgré tout cette association caritative
à un besoin constant de bonne volonté et
surtout d'argent frais reportage à
liévin dans le nord marianne masse
dominique maes l'ix20 dans le bassin
minier 34 mille habitants dans soixante
bénévoles du secours catholique
leur quotidien c'est l'exclusion
multiforme aides sociales logement
endettement réinsertion le secours
catholique a dû diversifier ses actions
pour répondre à une demande croissante
pour cela il lui faut défend bien sûr
mais aussi des bénévoles
c'est vrai qu'il ya une crise de
l'engagement n'est un repli en même
temps en temps des gens met le doigt
dans l'engrenage quand ils se disent
finalement ce qui est important dans ma
vie est ce que c'est ce que je vais ce
que je vais laisser sur mon yvette
caisse d'epargne ce que j'aurais fait
pour d'autres
s'il accepte d'entrer dans cette
démarche qui est d'abord aimer les gens
avant d'aimer l'argent à ce moment là on
va loin avec ici une bonne partie des
bénévoles ont été eux mêmes aidés par le
secours catholique comme augustin qik
est aujourd'hui en famille
j'étais chômeur aussi pendant six ans
alors ils m'ont aidé alors maintenant je
retravaille un peu sur ma demande est au
travail
et comme une mauvaise idée cela revête
ce bénévole l'association du secours
catholique dépend bien sûr de l'église
auparavant les collectes étaient même
effectué au sortie des messes
mais fidèle aussi se font rares à liévin
c'est la première année que la quête se
fait sur la voie publique mais on se
refuse à tout prosélytisme
il ya un coin de solidarité dans le
monde catholique
donc ya pas que les personnes qui sont
croyants qu'ils sont catholiques qui
font ça c'est une bonne action
les gens sont très dévoués c'était tout
marche - pas toujours facile de faire
passer le message auprès d'une
population déjà très sollicité en fin
d'année mais aujourd'hui l'équipe de
liévin compte quand même sur 60 mille
francs de dons en pologne quelques 28
millions d'électeurs étaient appelés
aujourd'hui aux urnes pour trancher
entre le président sortant lech walesa
et l'ancien communiste
aleksander kwasniewski au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle les toutes
dernières estimations donnent une très
légère avance pour le président sortant
les valises à avec 51,1 % mais encore
une fois il s'agit d'estimations nous
aurons plus de précisions peut-être
avant la fin de ce journal est en tout
cas dans le dernier journal
nos envoyés spéciaux olivier lerner et
jean françois chauvey ont passé la
journée avec l'une des figures
historique de solidarnosc pour nice
l'afp geremek qui a pris ses distances
avec les valises à mais qui s'inquiètent
cependant d'un éventuel retour au
pouvoir d'un néo communistes
bronislaw geremek à voter pour son vieil
ami walesa mais entre les deux hommes ce
n'est plus ce que l'on peut appeler le
grand amour
encore un beau geste mais le coeur n'y
est plus vraiment geremek l'un des co
fondateur de solidarnosc qui à 63 ans
aujourd'hui fait figure de vieux
dinosaures les jeunes quand on les
interroge pense qu'il est mort depuis
longtemps mais geremek est bien vivant
il a voté corogne au premier tour
vanessa au deuxième tour pour barrer la
route aux communistes avant tout on dit
souvent devant les ac il dit beaucoup de
bêtises mais que finalement il en fait
peu est ce que c'est vrai et c'est mon
nom qui je crois est très souvent elle
va les a dit des choses inacceptables
mais il ne le réalise pas et
heureusement depuis 43 ans
les guerres et meeke occupent sept
appartements d'état à deux pas de la
grand-place le coeur du vieux varsovie
ses voisins de palier qu'ils ont
espionné pendant l'état guerre en 1981
son parti rongé par la honte les autres
qui l'ont protégé à leurs risques et
périls lui rappelle sans cesse de vieux
souvenirs
ce soir geremek nerveux attendait les
premiers résultats sortis des urnes
un deuxième tour une semaine agitée où
les affaires ont fait la une de
l'actualité emplois là surtout le
deuxième tour la comac trident ciel
introduit ce problème de larges zones
d'activités économiques
et puis il ya eu une réaction sociale
qui est dangereux
voilà tous ces politiciens sont pour et
on a vu aujourd'hui dans varsovie des
soldats sans armes
mais ils étaient fort nombreux varsovie
a la tête qui tourne un peu ce soir avec
des communistes majorité au parlement
fort bien représenté au gouvernement est
capable de priver walesa d'un deuxième
mandat
quoi qu'il arrive le communisme n'est
pas mort en pologne
à paris l'avenir du processus de paix au
proche orient et la mémoire d'itzhak
rabin ont été évoqués hier soir lors du
traditionnel dîner annuel du conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
france le crif dîner présidé par alain
juppé cela en présence également de
michel rocard ou de lionel jospin et
surtout pour la première fois de la
représentante de l'ol paie à paris
reportage dominique 7 aux roses
jean françois est qu il y a un an cette
poignée de main aurait été impensable
leïla shahid un porte parole de l'ump en
france n'avait jamais été invitée par la
communauté juive mais le processus de
paix passés par là l'assassinât d'itzhak
rabin aussi quelque chose
un vraiment change c'est une première la
grande leçon à tirer de cet assassinat
c'est maintenant devenu évident que la
ligne de démarcation n'est plus du tout
entre palestiniens et israéliens juifs
et arabes
les partisans de la paix et
et qui inclut des palestiniens des
israéliens des arabes
les opposants de la paix qui inclut
aussi des palestiniens des ailières
l'avait déjà ici
plus traditionnel la présence des
politiques alain juppé lionel jospin
michel rocard tous autour de la même
table tous d'accord sur au moins un
point
la réconciliation entre juifs et
palestiniens était sensé est la tragédie
qui vient de frapper israël à travers la
perte de son premier ministre
c'est un signe de plus que le
vers la paix vaches poursuivre cette
initiative marque la volonté qui est la
nôtre à tous ne soyons d'aider le
processus de paix faire en sorte que la
paix avance ce sera sans doute la plus
belle victoire de sa cabine alain juppé
qui s'est aussi félicité du soutien des
différentes communautés pendant la vague
d'attentats en france
hier c'est bel et bien la paix qui a
marqué des points sur le terrain deux
semaines après le meurtre du premier
ministre d'israël le processus de paix
se poursuit yasser arafat le chef de
l'autorité palestinienne s'est en effet
rendu ce matin pour la première fois
dans la ville de jénine en cisjordanie
dont l'armée israélienne s'est retirée
la semaine dernière aux termes de
l'accord signé à washington en septembre
dernier devant plusieurs milliers de
personnes en liesse vous voyez yasser
arafat a appelé les palestiniens
participer massivement aux élections
livre prévue le 20 janvier prochain au
pakistan attentats meurtriers dans
l'ambassade d'égypte à islamabad cet
attentat à la bombe a été revendiqué par
plusieurs mouvements intégristes
égyptien il a fait au moins 14 morts et
une soixantaine de blessés
françoise joly il n'y a plus de mur
d'enceinte autour de l'ambassade
d'égypte une première bombe a ouvert le
passage à une voiture piégée
il est 11h ce matin le véhicule m'a
pénétré de quelques mètres dans la
mission diplomatique égyptienne avant
d'exploser
l'ondé de choc provoquera des dégâts
dans tout le quartier où sont situés la
plupart des ambassades notamment cinq de
france à 250 mètres du bâtiment égyptien
est une autre plus faible que j'avais
entendu en montant les escaliers et
cette explosion de correspondre et
d'explosifs une charge de 500 kg de
terre
le pakistan est considéré comme une
plaque tournante du terrorisme
international mais jamais islamabad
n'avait connu de telle attendra ce soir
au caire
au moins trois organisation intégriste
égyptienne revendique cet attentat au
sri-lanka des milliers de soldats
soutenus par des chars et par
l'artillerie ont pénétré ce matin dans
la ville de jaf n'a le bastion des
rebelles séparatistes tamouls dans le
nord de cette île les combats auraient
d'ores et déjà fait au moins 160 morts
en grèce fin de la mutinerie à la prison
athénienne de korydallos la mutinerie
une maîtrise d'une violence sans
précédent qui a duré six jours et dont
le bilan s'élève à quatre morts et une
soixantaine de blessés
a madrid quelques 8000 nostalgiques du
franquisme se sont rassemblés ce
dimanche pour commémorer le 20e
anniversaire de la mort du général
franco carmen fille unique du dictateur
présidé cette manifestation sous l'oeil
vigilant des forces de l'ordre environ
3000 militants de gauche avaient
organisé une contre-manifestation loin
de là mais il n'y a eu aucun incident un
sondage indique que le roi juan carlos
demeure la personnalité la plus estimée
des espagnols précisément pour son rôle
dans la transition de ce pays vers la
démocratie
le 20 novembre 45 il y aura 50 ans
demain 22 responsables politiques et
militaires du 3e reich comparaissait à
nuremberg devant un tribunal militaire
international
un procès qui durera près d'un mois et
qui verra la condamnation à mort de
douze dirigeants nazis notamment hermann
goering martin bormann ou encore joachim
von ribbentrop rappelle signé didier
epelbaum
ce fut nuremberg car hitler l'avait
choisie comme capitale du nazisme 7 à
nuremberg qui la promulguer les lois
racistes et antisémites de 35
c'est là que le régime a atteint le
sommet de son délire architectural et
rituels après la défaite
nuremberg est un champ de ruines deux
immeubles ont été épargné par les
bombardements
la prison mais le palais de justice
deezer le 20 novembre 45 premières
audiences en tête des huit magistrats
deux français la france est présente
mais son rôle est mineure
pour la très longue négociation est très
difficile négociation qui a mis sur pied
le tribunal à londres elle a envoyé un
excellent juge le juge falco qui a était
tout seul pour représenter la france
alors qu'il y avait des centaines
d'américains les dizaine d'anglais et il
n'avait pas de moyens pas d'interprète
pas de secrétariat
tant que la france ne s'est pas
réellement investi dans ce procès
pourtant c'est la première fois que l'on
juge les dirigeants d'un pays les chefs
de l'allemagne nazie la puissance
occupante 21 fidèles d'hitler de la
première heure sont là
non coupable non coupable
accusé de crimes de guerre et de crimes
contre l'humanité ils plaident tous non
coupable un seul système de dépenses
nous n'étions que des exécutants nous
avons contre signé les ordres d'hitler
sans les lire nous ignorions tout du
génocide le 1er octobre 46 ils sont tous
reconnus coupables
douze sont condamnés à mort et pendu
quinze jours plus tard de ce suicide
les autres feront de la prison au fil du
procès qui a moins intéressé les
français que le procès pétain
on a jugé de plus en plus les crimes de
guerre et de moins en moins les crimes
contre l'humanité le juge français dit
qu'il s'est volatilisée au moment du
jugement le crime contre l'humanité
allure en verre
le procès de nuremberg était sans
précédent cinquante ans plus tard il est
toujours sans postérité
c'est seulement depuis quelques mois que
s'est installée à l'est
un tribunal qui doit juger les crimes
contre l'humanité en ex yougoslavie et
au rwanda
la navette américaine atlantis s'est
séparé hier de la station orbitale russe
mir avant de retrouver le plancher des
vaches demain soir grâce à une caméra
placée sur un bras articulé de leur
navette l'équipage américain a envoyé
ses superbes vos images tournées au
dessus de l'arabie saoudite à quelques
400 km dans l'espace
survolant la bourgogne ses astronautes
d'atlantis aurait pu apercevoir avec de
très très bons yeux catherine deneuve
présidé la 135e vente des vins des
hospices de beaune
une vente qui s'est déroulée cette année
dans un climat incertain
et cela en raison de l'absence de l'un
des plus gros acheteurs traditionnels
reportage jean yves perrin fit montois
si pendant la vente des hospices de
beaune il y a toujours un moment où les
enchères s'affolent
cette année c'était pour catherine
deneuve marraine de l'association
solidarité enfants sida qui va
bénéficier de la vente d'une barrique de
meursault évidemment le prix des autres
cuvées n'a jamais atteint ces sommets
tout le monde craignait l'absence du
principal acheteur des hospices il
prenait d'habitude le quart du vin
proposé mais aujourd'hui les cours se
sont plutôt bien tenues voisins de ceux
de l'an dernier
la vente est venu je tuerai avec une
petite c'est à dire qu'elle correspond à
l'état du marché une stabilité stabilité
il ya des acheteurs dans la salle elle
est animée et
si l'amendé d'un bon rapport qualité
prix dans le millésime 95 et les
négociants ne sont pas les seuls à se
satisfaire de la tournure que prend
l'événement on arrive à des décors qui
sont plus en rapport avec le vrai prix
du marché on a des 20 95 c'est un très
bon millésime humains sont qualité
montant à mon avis alors pris le
négociant bourguignon le privilège
d'acheter aux amateurs de vins le
privilège de goûter mais seulement
pendant deux jours pour une somme
modique 80 francs tout le monde peut
venir se rendre compte du millésime sur
pièces dans les caves des hospices 39
cuvées différentes
un parcours pas toujours facile c'est un
petit peu dur les premiers sur les
tasses de café du matin dit peu dur
mortain
et c'est ça qui fait de cette vente de
charité
une véritable fête populaire miss
venezuela a été couronnée miss monde la
nuit dernière en afrique du sud
jacquerie de marcano 19 ans rêve de
devenir présentatrice du journal
télévisé après avoir terminé ses études
le problème c'est que christophe tortora
refuse obstinément de communiquer son
téléphone à jean pierre elkabbach
jacqueline à 19 ans elle rêve de devenir
présentatrice de journal télévisé et à
la rédaction de france 2 on caresse le
fol espoir de la voir arriver parmi nous
au venezuela
jacqueline étudie les relations
internationales
elle était venue en afrique du sud tout
simplement pour gagner
le jury n'a pas résisté à ce sourire
charmeur la cérémonie s'est déroulée
hier soir à sun city devant un milliard
et demi de téléspectateurs
jacqueline elle l'a plongée et la
littérature
hier soir elle s'est vu remettre un prix
de 400 mille francs et de somptueux
cadeaux en un instant elle est devenue
riche et célèbre belle très belle elle
l'était déjà
et j'en connais plus d'un prêt à se
faire douce violence pour faire un bébé
à miss monde transition quelque peu
graveleuses joue la corde pour
introduire le reportage suivant consacré
au salon du bébé et de la future maman à
l'espace champerret à paris jusqu'à
demain en compagnie de josée blanc
lapierre et de marie pierre cassignard
un petit tour des nouveautés sa maman et
sportives et pour la suivre partout
la petite manon a trouvé la solution la
poussette à trois roues une trouvaille
qui fait fureur aux états unis et qui
permet de faire son jogging avec le
petit dernier un peu de patience la
poussette week end fera ses premiers pas
en france en janvier
en attendant la maman pressée pourra se
consoler avec le biberon tout-terrain
emmailloté dans une enveloppe auto
chauffante
le lait de bébé atteint les 40 degrés en
dix minutes
pas de prise électrique ni casserole le
chauffe biberon est autonome et peut
s'emporter partout par ignorance a
attiré notre attention
ça paraissait processus yeux fondera
elle attend son bébé pour le printemps
mais elle ne pourra sans doute pas
accouché sur ce drôle d'engin un
prototype entre la balancelle le
fauteuil à bascule avec télécommande
intégrée c'est agréable sans moins
stressé ou pas on a les pieds dans la
système fois dans le temps d'accoucher
de cette façon la con
ainsi une fois l'accouchement passé il
faudra bien les habiller vos chers
petits et les publicitaires le savent
vous ne pourrez rien leur refuser cela
s'appelle un marché en pleine expansion
au salon on a calculé qu'entre les
couches le landau la layette et le
chauffe biberon un couple dépense en
moyenne quinze mille francs pour son
premier d'aidé
sans compter le schapi vente peu banale
demain et mardi chez christie's à
londres avec la mise aux enchères de
tous les biens qui se trouvaient dans
l'appartement du danseur rudolph noureev
mort du sida en janvier et 93
au total une impressionnante collection
d'objets d'art mais aussi de costumes de
scène estimée à environ 16 millions de
francs
reportage à l'ong bernard lebrun il
était né dans le wagon d'un train près
d'irkut là-bas en sibérie sur les rives
du lac baïkal et c'est au pied de
l'oural à oufa qu'il a grandi dans le
froid et la faim disait-il son père
militaire de l'armée rouge à l'est de
quasiment caserne sa mère femme tatars
de kazan descendait d'un peuple nomade
alors toute sa vie où dois-je noureev à
rêver de maisons et à aménager des
maisons de rêve comme sa dernière
habitation à paris au bord de la seine
ici au numéro 23 du quai voltaire face
au louvre
là où les richesses de l'orient et de
l'occident se mêler comme sur un bazar
de samarcande
et
les collections de toute une vie ont
traversé la manche et seront dispersées
lundi et mardi dans cette salle des
ventes
pour lui rendre un dernier hommage dit
le vendeur mais aussi pour attirer le
chaland
l'appartement du quai voltaire a été
reconstituée profits attendus des
trésors du danseur 16 millions de francs
le moindre chaussons du danseur sera mis
aux enchères
en revanche il n'est pas question de
disperser sa collection de films ni
certaines oeuvres d'art exposées ici qui
devrait bientôt être léguée à un musée
paris nous sommes en train de parler
avec plusieurs musées à paris
on espère bien de pouvoir établir un tel
l'année prochaine disons travail à
l'opéra garnier 20 ans de danse à covent
garden à londres
il n'y aura pas de musée noureev mais
les anglais le dise ou dit comme il
l'appelait leur a déjà tous des danses
toujours mais sur glace ou à bercy le
trophée lalique a connu cette année
encore un formidable succès populaire
claire rennes ou encore sous le charme a
sélectionné pour nous quatre temps forts
dramatique
l'interprétation très théâtral des
derniers instants de raspoutine par les
russes natalia estemirova et andry
bookeen champions olympiques de danse
sur glace en 1981
acrobatique l'alléluia les américains
anita ressort n'est franxault ennemis
déclarés vainqueurs de ce trophée
lalique
romantique
la belle au bois dormant de tchaïkovski
revisité par les jeunes mariés
finlandais les champions d'europe susan
harraka mot et peut cliquer au co
enfin féerique le roméo et juliette de
marine akimova et sergei ponomarenko les
champions olympiques d'albertville ont
littéralement fait fondre le coeur des
spectateurs parisiens
toujours dans la grâce que peut-on rêver
de mieux que de terminer ce journal en
compagnie de madame butterfly l'opéra le
plus célèbre de puccini a été mise en
image par frédéric mitterrand c'est son
deuxième long métrage depuis lettres
d'amour en somalie en 81 l'aboutissement
d'un rêve
reportage bruno albin rejet mature un
vrai baiser de cinéma rsa du rsa dû à
cette juriste ans
butterfly n'est pas seulement un grand
opéra de puccini dit frédéric mitterrand
c'est un modèle de scénario et il a
filmé l'histoire de la geisha de
nagasaki abandonné parking cartonne à
président de parodie de mariage comme
une histoire très contemporaine
la petite soeur de bien des jeunes
filles qui espère dans bien des villes
du monde qu'un étranger les sortira de
leur condition rien de plus exotique
pour un jeune officier en escale qu'une
hausse pour rire
peu importe au fond cette femme qui
croit devenir américaine est on avec les
siens il est exactement comme ces
officiers américains qui ont brillé dans
les années 40 à wailly qui se mariait
des belles du pacifique vln a dans tant
de films des années 50
butterfly n'est pas de l'opéra film et
c'est un film tout court affirme le
metteur en scène une belle histoire
proche de nous et dont les personnages
chantent
il a sorti l'action du terrain à trac
mais en restant fidèle à la partition de
coups de chine en permettant de suivre
le récit de beaucoup plus près et et
d'une manière qui est peut-être plus
intimes
je crois qu'on veut aussi la musique
plus proche plus familière et que l'omb
augmente encore sa charge d'émotion
mais potter fly lag et chats abandonnés
qui se voulait américaine meurt comme
une japonaise qui ne peut vivre dans
l'honneur doit mourir dans l'honneur des
samouraïs mélodramatique
oui et frédéric mitterrand revendique ce
mélodrame qui permet très souvent dit-il
d'exprimer toute la force des sentiments
bravo frédéric mais pourquoi donc
puccini ati le baptiser son héroïne
madame mouchabeurre sur cette
angoissante question je vous donne
rendez-vous dans quelques minutes avec
gérard depardieu christophe colomb avant
taratata invité l'egypte ims j'arrivais
pas vers israël vers 00h40 en compagnie
de florence dauchez demain à 7h50 rémy
roche recevra dans les 4 vérités robert
hue secrétaire nationale du parti
communiste dans un instant la météo de
nathalie rihouet avec un lundi froid et
ensoleillé
demain à 13h retrouver patrick chesnais
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver à
20h excellente soirée merci